chewing and chewing all around the mouth
of the chicken goes no opinion on the
taste and then suddenly it's like hey we
have a consensus
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
week Feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today we're joined by John mullaney he's
an Emmy award-winning writer and
comedian who Rose to prominence during
his time at Saturday Night Live and the
time since he's done everything from the
claim Broadway show to a children's
Musical and a number of beloved comedy
specials including his latest Baby J
which is now available to stream on
Netflix John Mulaney welcome to the show
Sean thank you for having me do you let
viewers know that it's 11 A.M you know
it sometimes it comes up a long way you
know okay but and that for some this is
their first anything that they've tasted
for the day you and I both are having
hot sauce for breakfast and you're right
I think it is important to be
transparent about that fact to the
audience watching maybe or maybe not I
mean I just it just it's it's of note
thank you
[Music]
foreign
did you ever have braces no never my
life oh I did so I'm very conscious of
eating in public
because like in high school you would go
right don't worry John we're going to be
very kind in the edit John will be very
kind in the end I appreciate that I
appreciate that but I still have to do
my due diligence yeah make sure I don't
have chicken in my braces which I
haven't been there for 20 years
[Music]
very tasty
does intense scrutiny or intense media
scrutiny of a comedian's personal life
is that a force of good or force of evil
when it comes to writing new material
you know some people it doesn't take
media scrutiny for uh sometimes we
comedians just start to eat our own tail
and uh you know our new jokes refer to
our old jokes or a lot of it is stories
about being a comedian
um so it not so much media scrutiny but
more just uh
just
um cannibalizing your own life as a
comedian I think can be dangerous Waylon
Jennings I heard you know those Outlaw
country guys yeah yeah they had a lot of
songs about being Outlaw country guys
you know are you sure Hank Done It This
Way or don't you think this outlaw
business has done got out of hand yeah
yeah
um and someone said to Waylon Jennings
once you know you guys used to sing
about my life but now you just sing
about your own life
I thought that's kind of the the Peril
of of autobiographical comedy sometimes
Curry Verde what does that mean
green curry
I thought it meant true Verde for a
second I thought meant truth I was like
oh what an interesting name James green
curry
very very nice there we go two for two
over two
so as a teenager I understand that you
spent many a weekend pouring over
archival TV footage at Chicago's Museum
of broadcast Communications did you have
a favorite exhibit or curiosity like did
you ever find yourself marveling at Bozo
the Clown memorabilia or take a moment
to visit Edward R murrow's plaque at the
radio hall of fame
um I did see all those exhibits
um they also had stuff from like the
very first uh broadcasts ever and they
had these puppets called kukula Fran and
Ollie which I guess you know were the
original cocoa melon this was like the
hottest children's programming and
they're the rattiest little jive ass
1951 puppet you can't imagine that this
was a show but it was
um they just look like socks or like the
leather thing you put over a golf driver
um that stuff was interesting to me I
went into the archives though because
um my parents got me this thing that was
the best of Johnny Carson so it was like
a video and it had all these famous
clips of Johnny Carson on it so I was
really interested in that as most 10
year olds are
um so I went down
just to watch full episodes of Carson
just like a full episode from a random
day in 1971 and see what it was like and
it was interesting because they're not
that good like they're not all you know
not every people look back on that sort
of uh you just you pick I mean if you're
on the air for 30 years and you have
five good bits a year you've got you
know endless reels of the best of but it
was nice to see just sort of Meandering
interviews bad monologues it's really
comforting in a way it was comforting in
a way yes as I began my career as a
broadcaster type they're not all they're
not all hits
[Music]
what does that mean lemon pepper
it means uh green curry
it means Curry of Truth
is this a light flavor
yeah we're still in sort of a delicate
touch kind of oh no I assume I assume uh
from how many we have that you have to
make yourself but also just in general
this is a little even lighter than yeah
the last one yeah we're pulling yeah
yeah we're moving uh some levers we're
pulling some levers over here yeah
psychological games shades of light and
dark yes that's very good
no need to name names but what's the
worst reaction you ever recall getting
from an SNL celebrity host to a sketch
that you've pitched them in
[Music]
Brolin
you said name names right no no Josh
Brolin went well this isn't funny as I
was writing something and I started to
walk him through it and he went yeah no
but that but that's not funny and it was
so a matter of fact I wouldn't even call
it the worst I found it it's actually
like valuable feedback completely
valuable and it was early enough on
Tuesday night that I didn't proceed with
it it actually was I I I'm not answering
your question because it was such a
gentlemanly exchange of ideas hey Josh
Brolin do you like this idea let me see
no that's not funny that I I actually he
did me quite a service
um there were others who uh I remember
we had a joke when Mick Jagger hosted
that was uh
uh hey everyone I'm Mick Jagger so
mothers lock up your daughters and
daughters lock up your mothers
um and he listened and he went no I
don't like that
and uh I actually remember I made Seth
Meyers read that one because I was going
over a bunch of jokes and we got to that
one it was it was uh it was let me redo
that the joke was uh I'm Mick Jagger so
mothers lock up your daughters or should
I say daughters lock up your mothers and
when we got to that one I just handed it
to Seth and was like and then there's
that one you could read that one
[Music]
what is this one so this one right here
Chile lengua de Fuego don't ask me what
it means I have no idea the curry of
Truth in the Latin
what do you remember about performing at
the note and Wicker Park was that like
the first place that you ever tried
stand-up yes uh I was 18 I did uh sort
of like um there was a variety show at
the note
um I remember being very frustrated that
I wasn't way way better immediately
after watching comedians for 18 years I
really wanted to begin at that level I
yes and I I really had no tolerance for
my own level at that moment and uh but
it was it was very fun it was one of
those things where and this is a lot of
early comedy the audience is the other
people performing and then in the very
very beginning it's often a bunch of
people that you invited uh family and
friends who you're then quite resentful
are there once you get up and it's not
going that great you're like and why all
these [__] God damn it
well look at you now John look at you
now look at me now 11 A.M pounding chick
[Music]
how long does it take taste to hit your
brain I would say I'm like 30 seconds I
would put 30 I would put it I'm
surprised how long
some of these it's um you take a bite
you think you're in there I'm chewing
I'm chewing I'm chewing no opinion is
forming on the tastes chewing and
chewing all around the mouth the chicken
goes no opinion on the taste and then
suddenly it's like hey we have a
consensus
laughs
this is really nice
so earlier this month more than 11 000
TV and film writers went on strike
marking the first stoppage of its kind
in the streaming era let's say this
thing stretches until like November or
December what does that actually mean
for the people who love TV and movies in
your opinion ooh um it'd be interesting
to see uh now if I were to be uh a touch
cynical
um there's a lot of content already out
there
um and you know I feel like we've all
been saying that for years like God
there's so many shows there's so many
shows there's so many shows and uh now
we'll see how many there are
you only have the ones you have
um if everyone's just gonna continue
watching
streaming TV I I wonder when it will hit
a point where you go oh there's not it's
as a viewer it's frustrating that
there's not new stuff what to you like
if you take money out of the equation
like what do you think is the most
important wedge issue that's like at
stake in this negotiation because so
much has changed since 2007 in the last
one it's interesting on the picket line
I've heard more and more about AI which
I thought was
um I thought was not a fringe issue but
kind of off to the side but maybe as a
comedy writer like
maybe you're sort of insulated because I
don't imagine AI being like funny
okay
um I also am very confident that there
is something about
uh the that there is a profound
difference between knowing you're
hearing a joke from a person and knowing
you're hearing it from Ai and the
audience isn't just looking for the
actual like a mechanical of the
mechanical yeah
um but I have famously terrible
instincts and I
um I I've never known what's gonna
happen in the future so what do I
um but uh I have heard AI jokes that are
solid and or or they're solid sorry
there I wouldn't call them crossing over
into good but they're solid
um so maybe AI could replace that you
know that 15th joke in an award show
monologue that's fine and it
acknowledges you know when they have to
acknowledge a movie that's nominated or
something but like the joke isn't that
good maybe AI could provide well only
time will tell I guess only ready to
move on here to the back half John yeah
absolutely so this is the spicy shark
here in the sick spot spicy shop work
born in New England
famously spicy place
known for
its indigenous chilies
indigenous chilies curries
and paprikas
[Music]
yeah I can already feel it yeah you know
what it is as it hits the back of the
top or it tastes like a sweeter sauce
that's gone bad
oh this is a nice flavor oh but it it's
been out in the sun it was sitting on
the dashboard while we were parked in a
Target parking lot
so in 2020 you were nominated for a pair
of Emmys for your musical special the
sac launch bunch a project you've
described as being as satisfying as
anything I've ever done what's the
origin story of Grandma's got a
boyfriend clearly a song very much
shaped by an enthusiasm for musical
theater Grandma's got a boyfriend uh
came from my nana having a boyfriend a
wonderful guy named David they began
dating I think when I was 10. it was
just if I knew immediately as a kid I go
this is a funny predicament
um you know that's my grandma's
boyfriend it just was funny right away
then you get to see your mom and aunts
and uncles grown people
um having a sort of you're not my dad
uh reaction which I'm being very general
and I'm glossing over tons of nuance in
terms of my own family and how they uh
appreciated and loved David
um but there there was that you know in
some ways
um just because it's new uh it was so
funny to me I did and they they had so
many opinions on it and uh I remember my
grandma's boyfriend uh I remember my
grace my grandma's boyfriend called the
house once and my aunt picked up not my
nana and uh she went hello and he went
well swam on Sherry and she was like
what David and everyone made fun of me
thank you
adobo Loco that means craziness
I'd actually say this is this is seven
this is quite good wow is it your
favorite one so far uh
a little bit in that I like the base
flavor the most okay interesting
interesting like it is that smokier
taste
there's a little bit of barbecue sauce
has a feeling of a Worcester sheer sauce
has a slight steak sauce feel
I like that there we go talk about a
crazy Abode
they're not lying they ain't lying
change as crazy as a bodes I've ever
walked in absolutely crazy
people kind of don't remember that these
shows like best week ever actually had
really funny people like you and Michael
Che on them did you find that to be like
a good way to drill comedy or are they
kind of different skill sets no best
week ever was a great training ground
especially for Saturday Night Live you
just you have these you know rather dry
prompts of something that happened in
the news and you have to come up with
five jokes for it but in general
um I liked assignment writing I still
like assignment writing like if I write
a joke for someone's award show
monologue and they do it watching that I
think I think that's the most satisfying
thing still really you're like you'll
watch someone else hit the Home Run and
and then whoever I'm with I go that was
my joke
that it really is it it really is fun
does it does it no it's also funny when
it doesn't work yeah that's what I was
gonna very funny when it doesn't work do
you imagine because they trusted you
it has a missile on it and it's called
the bomb and it's called Beyond insanity
for a consensus I feel like on that one
it was when it got here
I knew it was gonna be bad yeah and
that's saying a lot I've done a lot of
damage to my synapses and I could tell
right away
okay first impressions yeah it's very
hot right goes without saying it's a hot
sauce system huh it's beyond insane some
might say
um it's not good
it's not good food you understand yeah
yeah it doesn't make food better I
follow
um
I'm not trying to damage their business
not a good product I think this is their
business and product is missing the
Target that much
but you're kind of like straight face
well taking it to the Dome it's kind of
interesting amazing to behold honestly
but please I I appreciate that but as we
both know neither of us likes
compliments
um
certainly hot but it is I'm more struck
by the flavor isn't the flavor's
metallic and poisonous kind of
it just sucks yeah
it's just not a thing where you go you
know I'm gonna get I'm gonna put a
little debomb on this yeah
do you have a Mount Rushmore of comedy
albums the top four of all time ooh and
tears are coming down my face now I feel
me too yeah shared suffering right here
sure okay Florida chisel into the stone
there we go
uh strategic Grill locations Mitch
Hedberg
it felt at the time like there were lots
of Hedberg imitators but I think in
large part they've Fallen away and now
you're just left with this totally
singular voice
I mean at one point he just says I wish
I had a briefcase handcuffed to my Wrist
all right like that there's no joke
either it's just a fun thought that he
had that that was always very inspiring
to me sometimes you can just say things
that aren't even like set up punchline
I've never cried this way yeah where I'm
not actually feeling if they're just
rolling down the side of my face
bring the pain Chris rocks bring the
bank very very unique very against the
grain
in late high school I got I think all of
Eddie izard's albums up to that time uh
Dressed to Kill
um
I can't remember the one where he does
the Old Testament and the New Testament
great great album
um Dave Attell skanks For The Memories
that's just the Best comedian to ever
perform in clubs at the absolute top of
his game it's just a great
great record
um
record sounding like
it's the sauce you know 80 year old man
yeah it's aging you it's aging me a lot
yeah
Alchemy
[Music]
I should slow down because something
might hit me that I'm not aware of yet
but at first I wasn't gonna get in your
way I just like letting the runaway
train go you know I'm just trying to
keep up tastes like fish food
oh you know what I've
do you taste that yeah well I've only
ever smelled fish food but I'm actually
I'm making the connection right now
thank you let me be clear
it tastes like how fish food I know why
I'm so uh defensive like if I eat fish
food that's fine that's my choice
um did you ever have goldfish no never
in my life really in my life no yeah
here's the problem when you were a kid
is especially if you like taking care of
people
um
you want to feed them more but that
you're not supposed and it's you're like
you're like you guys and I know there's
only one thing I ever give you and I
gave it to you already today but you're
still there and
I want you to like me
and I want you to tell other fish that
I'm a good guy so I'd love to feed you
again and again and again but you can't
you can't do that it's really hard I
think it's a very beneficial owner it's
a very good test for people pleasing
children can you can you have a boundary
with this fish right and it's food
and it's hard because if you know but
the results of that you could kill the
fish it's really stressful I know I know
it's [__] up actually I I relate I
relate let's find a new way to feed fish
where you can do it multiple times yeah
you don't have to be supported
emotionally are in these flakes where if
they have it twice they die
sounds like uh it's a problem with the
food manufacturer these are questions
not enough people are asking John you
know no one's asking no one's asking
that's like that you know that's Chris
Rock really inspired me I say the [__]
everyone think of it yeah they're afraid
to say it but they're just afraid to say
it they're afraid I face the stage and I
take down fish food one flake at a time
do you recommend just one tap this is a
nice little tap you see yours
[Laughter]
okay how do you feel about that I feel
that looks great okay that looks great I
don't want the comments to be like
that's no tap get a good close-up
I don't know why I'm trying to do this
you really don't have to I know
it's like with fish though you just want
to explore please them
okay Cheers Cheers John what a ride this
is called the last dab Apollo
Tangy
this is still food though right
exactly the bomb is something else a
cologne Maybe yeah maybe just
all right
like I'm still eating this I know I can
see that and actually it looks like
you've cleaned pretty much the whole
plate now this is the bomb I believe
whoa no they're not going back yeah yeah
no I'm not going back but that one I did
not
do too much damage but you know what for
11 in the morning that is wreaking havoc
right there and to close things out John
we have a little bit of a surprise for
you all right so you can close out your
special with this eight minute long
autopsy for an interview that you did
with gq's Frasier Tharp yes
Frasier Tharp used to work in this very
building he walked these very halls and
thankfully his contact information is
still active so we reached out to
Frazier to give you the final wingten
question so this is the Fraser Tharp
with a wingten question for you all
right
my question to you is at what point did
you realize when you were writing uh
from scratch and will become Baby J that
you wanted to take our interview and
make it not only a big part of the
special but the grand finale
it's good to see Frasier he's just like
I remembered him
the first time I got on stage after
being
um away in a rehab for a couple months
was in May of 2021 at the City Winery in
New York on the West Side Highway and I
don't know if I opened with the
interview but I
um got to it pretty quickly
maybe the fourth or fifth night I was
doing City Winery Chris Rock came by he
said you should walk out and immediately
open with the intervention and I did for
a long time
um and so I did that that night so I had
to put the interview because it had such
big laughs by that point last to close
the show so it started closing the show
in May of 2021. it was very
I I remember when it came out the
interview I was in rehab and I was
reading it and it was a very bad time in
life
um I did think to myself this is very
funny well John yes
[Music]
the wings of death a distant memory that
we can look back on like old Johnny
Carson episodes yeah you have lived to
tell the tale and now there's nothing
left to do but roll out the red carpet
for you this camera this camera this
camera let the people know what you have
going on in your life oh thank you I
didn't know this was part of it hi it's
me from all the wings uh amazing to be
part of a 21st season of something
um it uh it's an honor to have been here
um it was very interesting to go through
these
um you they really paced them out in a
way that uh you think you're safe and
then they kick you again like it's not
just easy to hard it's not a perfect
curve I have a special called Baby J on
Netflix
um I'm very proud of it I've enjoyed all
my comedy specials but this one I think
is the best I've done I hope you check
it out and I hope you enjoy it but more
importantly I hope you check it out
because that means uh it gets streaming
ratings that I will never uh get any
information on
um I also uh have nothing else coming up
there's a writer's strike
um I'll be picketing maybe Warner
Brothers at some point come out and
bring us water or something nice like
that
um and
that's it oh I'll continue being a
comedian
thanks thanks
John
and that's the hot ones experience that
was amazing
I might have already kind of burned off
some taste buds like I don't know how
good this is but I did think to myself
like this is actually something I would
have again well you know what we're
gonna pack it up and and you can have it
hey
well then if I'm taking it home yeah
yeah you might want to figure out how to
put that on dang this was awesome Sean
thank you you had a good like you had a
good time great oh thank you you're the
best researcher you didn't ask me
anything I've ever been asked before
thank you everybody
hey what's going on hot ones fans this
is Sean Evans if you've ever watched hot
ones and wondered to yourself how hot
are those sauces really I could get
through that with no water or milk well
now is the time to put your money where
your mouth is the hot ones season 21
lineup is now available in its entirety
at heatness.com heatness.com that's
heatness.com to get your hands on the
season 21 hot Ones hot sauce lineup milk
not included be careful around the eyes
and get them while they're hot
London